hey youtubers it's Charlie so they
finally released the official version of
the ant-man post-credit scene so I
thought it was time to talk about
Captain America Civil War we have a
trailer coming up so here's the clip
just in case you haven't seen it then
we're gonna break it down
this would have been a lot easier week
ago if we call Tony how he won't believe
us even if he did who knows what their
car is a lot of help we're on our own
maybe not
I know a guy so they're really like two
big things going on here one you have
ant-man officially joining team cap he's
like a total fangirl it's the most
adorable thing ever and then you have
them finding Bucky when they say air
quotes this would have been easier last
week they're talking about the
government taking a huge dump on
superheroes a bunch of information about
all the shady stuff that's been going on
goes public so everybody knows that the
Winter Soldier is Bucky and he's a total
dirtbag so cap wants to save his friend
but he can't take him out in public
because they'll Lynch him of course at
the head of that mob is Tony Stark
he basically draws the line in the sand
like we need to keep these superheroes
aboveboard they have to be registered
they have to be monitored Kat thinks
that that's a big violation of civil
liberties so of course there you have
your Civil War unofficially it's like
Avengers 2.5 just because so many of the
Avengers are in the movie the biggest
notable absence that we know about is
Thor now he's gonna be dealing with
what's going on with Asgard during Thor
Ragnarok even though that movie isn't
coming out for a while in the timeline
it picks up relatively close to where
civil war is happening so that's why
he's not around when this is going down
but there's also the Hulk which is now
confirmed to be in Thor Ragnarok so he's
probably only gonna be mentioned in
passing during Civil War they said it
was just like too many people in civil
war for hope to make it in originally
Mark Ruffalo is supposed to have a spot
I guess he doesn't now either way
there's so many people in the movie you
won't notice the weird thing about
Marvel Studios when it comes to Civil
War is that originally they were gonna
do a very different story but then they
got spider-man so it started to move
closer and closer to comic-book Civil
War now obviously there's still going to
be a lot of differences because almost
every character that Marvel owns was
part of comic-book Civil War in Marvel
Studios can't put them all in the movie
because Fox owns a bunch of those Sony
owns a bunch of the other characters too
spider-man and Scarlet Witch are the
exceptions but Scarlet Witch and vision
are definitely in the movie I've already
done a video about what the teams are
supposed to be so I'll put a link for
that in the description but I know a lot
of you are asking what about TV shows
what about the Netflix shows like as
daredevil gonna show up in Civil War as
far as we know that is not gonna be the
case agents of shield always does some
kind of crossover hopefully it'll be
more exciting than the Avengers age of
Ultron crossover that was kind of a
disappointment so we'll see I'm not
expecting Coulson to show up in the
movies anytime soon especially after
Joss Whedon is like yeah for all intents
and purposes Coulson is still dead in
the movies the TV shows always kind of
have to dance between the movies
raindrops but speaking of TV shows
there's so much happening this week
Jessica Jones is dropping all 13
episodes are dropping on Friday usually
that happens at midnight I'm gonna do as
many videos as I can 4 episodes I don't
know if I'll be able to do a video for
every single episode so I might have to
do like one video for every two episodes
just to get them all out but I'll try
and get all of my Jessica Jones episode
videos out within like a one-week span
so I should at least post the jessica
jones video like once every two days I
mean just depends on how fast I get
through them all we also just found out
that agent Carter season two is gonna
premiere Tuesday January 5th so you
start the year off right doing what
Peggy says all the characters are going
to Los Angeles like Peggy's gonna be
based in Los Angeles Howard Stark buys a
movie studio they're gonna have Madame
ask a bunch more comic book characters
it's gonna be awesome and the cool thing
about agent Carter that's different from
agents of shield is that Marvel Studios
like the movie people helped make agent
Carter they don't do that for agents of
shield agents of shield was made by ABC
Studios Kevin Feige himself actually
helped make some agent Carter season 1
episodes so they just take a lot of
extra care with that show which is why
it looks fantastic we'll talk more about
agent Carter later in the year but
everybody asking about the civil war
trailer Marvel has already confirmed
that they're gonna drop it with Star
Wars The Force awakens
and when they say the trailer is gonna
drop with Star Wars they're talking
about the u.s. release date there are a
lot of countries where Star Wars is
being released a little bit earlier like
a couple days earlier I'm talking about
the US release on the 18th
so either the trailer is gonna drop
during that week like say on Tuesday the
15th or it's gonna drop on the actual
day that Star Wars drops on Friday the
18th so either way civil war trailer
that week and if you didn't see the
x-men trailer is totally jumping in the
doc pile Fox is dropping the official
x-men apocalypse trailer on that same
day so there is a ton of stuff
happening in December
don't worry like if you're not good with
dates you're not good with scheduling
stuff whenever I start shouting about
stuff you'll know it's happening like
whenever it starts going down I will
start freaking out it'll be awesome
later tonight I'm working on a new game
of Thrones video then we have new Gotham
most of the rest of this week is going
to be a pretty normal week
with the exception of Jessica Jones on
Friday so why you guys wait for
everything to post you can click here
for all my Captain America Civil War
videos and you can click here for all my
Jessica Jones videos thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight
you